[Music]
the theme song for many new parents who
faced a host of new challenges one of
the most common though dealing with
sleep issues when children don't fall
into a regular pattern of sleep parents
usually aren't sleeping much either but
finding a solution isn't just a dream so
called sleep coaches can diagnose sleep
problems and our recommended simple
solutions providing some much-needed
relief when we first brought our home
from the hospital within a couple of
days she was sleeping from about 11
o'clock at night until 5:00 or 6:00 in
the morning
you didn't think like we're home free
this is like compared to my friends I
thought oh my god this is this really is
amazing
first-time mom Ariel Burnham says that
amazing period of restful nights with
her newborn Cooper was short-lived you
just want to walk when Cooper outgrew
her bassinet she slept in her parents
bed until they got a mattress from her
crib suddenly it was taking a heroic
effort to get Cooper to sleep for even
small stretches of time to sleep I would
have to rock her and nurse her or carry
her around and sing to her for 45
minutes we were getting her into the
crib for maybe three or four hours and
then she would send the rest of the
night in bed with us and not really
sleeping just kind of nursing all night
at the all-you-can-eat buffet how was
your sleep during that time oh it was
it's non-existent new parents are often
asked how their baby sleeps at night for
many the answer is not well a recent
study in the journal Pediatrics found at
six months old only 43% of babies were
sleeping eight hour stretches and at 12
months old about 57% to train their
infants to sleep when they do wake in
the night some parents won't go to their
baby's crib or may delay feeding but for
others it's too difficult to ignore the
crying my husband and I were pretty
firmly against any of the traditional
sleeping methods we wanted to do
something as gentle as possible
I felt I didn't help her in the way that
she needed and that was I feel very
guilty
that's why Ariel Burnham called mommy
wise a company that provides 72 hours of
in-home coaching an additional
support after the promise according to
owner natalie vorous to get babies
sleeping through the night when I meet a
family as I first talked to them I
connect with them on the phone make sure
that there are a hundred percent a good
fit and that means that both caregivers
are aligned that they're okay with a
little bit of crying not endless crying
but a little bit of crying that they're
okay putting their baby in another room
the secret sauce is that we're there in
real time assessing what's actually
happening the plan for Cooper included
breaking her habit of Nursing to sleep
and moving her crib out of her parents
bedroom that's what a lot of babies are
used to they nurse to sleep they feed to
sleep they get rocked to sleep sleep
association is what we're changing
really all we're doing is putting the
baby down awake the strategy worked the
first night it took Cooper less than 15
minutes to fall asleep on her own by
night 2 Cooper slept nearly 13 hours you
can't get your child to sleep and you're
exhausted and all the different emotions
so what's the reverse emotion like when
you finally get it yeah it was elated to
sleep a whole night I mean it I it had
been you know almost 11 months
dr. Jennifer Xu is a pediatrician and
spokesperson for the American Academy of
Pediatrics despite how difficult it may
be to ignore a baby's cries while trying
to change their sleep patterns
she says doing so won't hurt them
limited periods of letting a baby cry
for several minutes every night for
about a week are not known to cause
long-lasting harm to the baby's
emotional and mental development dr. Xu
says good sleep habits should begin
early if a parent can expose their baby
to a lot of natural daylight and regular
noise throughout the day that can be
helpful to have the baby set their
internal clock and then starting about
seven o'clock at night make it dark and
quiet for your babies if a baby is
having trouble sleeping dr. Xu
recommends parents wait until babies are
four to six months old to start a sleep
training program with the blessing of a
pediatrician around 3,500 infants die
annually from sleep related deaths
including sudden infant death syndrome
to reduce that risk
the AAP recommends babies sleep on their
backs in a bear bassinet or crib and
that parents share a room with the baby
ideally for a whole year the idea that
the American Academy of Pediatrics says
that you should room share until the age
of 1 this is not that no if you've got
you know the room is right next to your
room and you've got your baby on a
monitor you can see and hear your baby
just as much as if your baby was in the
room the advice may seem simple but the
kind of personalized coaching mommy wise
provides is an investment with a price
tag of up to $7,500 in big cities like
New York
if somebody's wondering is it worth the
cost what would you say to them I know
that it is because her clients tell us
every day that it was money well spent
I know we've saved marriages I've seen
mothers who literally couldn't cope at
all so I know that it's a struggle for a
lot of parents and I wish that I could
help everyone the way she helped the
Burnham's who these days have a much
easier go with that
time for Mom Ariel sleeping like a baby
is priceless if this is something that
is within your means then I highly
recommend it and I think that there are
different options at different price
points for everybody
there should be no stigma attached with
seeking out help why do you think
there's a stigma associated with the
idea that you need somebody to help you
with your child
people see the bond of motherhood is
this kind of secret community and that
inviting outside help is some sort of
indication of a lack of ability if the
support and then the confidence that
somebody else can give you absolutely as
they're looking at this differently yeah
I mean and that's the I guess sometimes
all it takes right is a different
perspective and you know we don't have
that different perspective we don't have
families living as close necessarily so
your mom might not be there in Ariel
even said you're so sleep-deprived you
need somebody else when you back we
rethink my son did not sleep through the
night till he was 2 now in college
no Howard but but I remember the pain
and I should say you know that price
point is very high removed that's a big
city
prices range the services range so it is
something that people can look into for
the help okay
Margo slept through the night Thank You
Argo